embouteillage sur la ligne de départ de
l'eco-trail ils étaient près de 8000 à
s'élancer de plusieurs sites franciliens
pour rejoindre la tour eiffel ce samedi
sur l'épreuve reine de 80 km départ de
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
les concurrents se préparent à un effort
d'une extrême intensité
bah c'est la première fois que je le
faire j'ai déjà fait 67 km sur le trail
de chevreuse peur oui parce qu'on n'est
jamais sûr du résultat
peur de décevoir surtout mes peurs de
une grosse envie plutôt d'y arriver
voilà quelques années je ne sais pas moi
peut-être 40 ans d'entraînement mais je
continue toujours et ça me plaît autant
qu'on en a déjà fait l'année dernière au
40e kilomètre
la plupart s'entraîne exclusivement pour
cette course depuis trois mois par dose
d'une centaine de kilomètres par semaine
sur une distance aussi longue le trailer
bien sûr tout gérer son alimentation
mais aucun papier par terre sur le
parcours à chacun sa pochette poubelles
et sa tasse écologique c'est aussi ça
les cotrade prend le trail ça ça rime
hopper et qui colle au gie c'est pour
moi les ailes et trailer doivent aimer
la nature
et le fait que ce soit écologique c'est
plus long terme des 80 km sylvain court
s'est imposé en 5 heures 48 minutes et
58 secondes